vous devez savoir comment ce collectif
oui déjà prévu qu'un médecin peut faire
des tâches occupationnel pour jusqu'au
xxe secondes
moi je sais et ça ou vous n'êtes pas un
peu trop ce qu'on a entendu qu'il est
pas mal plus tech que ce que permet la
cobas collective parce que
éventuellement il va avoir un copain de
téléphone de mon frère au bureau comment
ça se fait que lui faso comment ça se
fait que lui face au puy moustachu chez
nous enfin que faut que je donne des
réponses remise elle s'est permis par la
convention électrique s'est produit à la
convention collective mais grâce à vous
par ma région je sais ce que c'est pas
un peu d'autres parce que vous êtes
toujours à ta musique les entrepreneurs
doivent respecter la convention
collective
mais ça c'est pas vous se placer la
société à sa voûte en bois vous le
concevez lancer dans votre région la
détache que presque pas de ce monsieur
monsieur le commissaire se porte ce
n'est pas que moi ça m'a personnellement
donc je payé par les travailleurs pour
voir à ce que les métiers soient
respectés puis voir à ce que les
travailleurs travaillent puis quand ça
fait quand on a des musées dans dans
notre région les téléphones s'arrête pas
pu me la mets bassam aux états on s'est
occupé de mon salaire quand ça arrive au
bureau le label par la nuit là ça fait
quatre fois qu'on attend dire qui fait
notre job bicici de saison donc
contentera donc à ce que tu as à faire
le coup de main on change jamais après
son mauvais mais la cause collective
permis que ce projet soit un coup de
main c'est peut être un certain temps
ajoute mon point c'est que vous vous
demandez aux employeurs de respecter
intégralement la cobas collectif mais
vous de votre bord vous le faites pas au
rsa seulement quand ça vous tente pas ou
que ce vous travaillerez que vous
demandez pas le faire serait de garder
ces dossiers c'est ça ben oui je
rouspète 0 id maire que vous une chose
c'est que c'est au niveau de la bouche
oui la pression a bien forte
puis je encore au sein des entrepreneurs
respectent pas toutes la convention même
si on lui demande de la respecter